- [Narrator] Located in Postojna, Slovenia
is a sturdy castle built
into a natural cavern,
halfway up a 400-foot cliff side.
(upbeat music)
Predjama Castle was built
in the thirteenth century,
in Gothic-styled architecture.
However, after a siege
in the sixteenth century,
the exterior was reconstructed
and is what you see today.
But there's more to this
castle than meets the eye.
Beneath it lays the Postojna Cave Park.
The caves are accessible
during May to September,
and closed in the winter,
so as not to disturb the
hibernating local bats.
The castle has changed ownership
throughout its history;
however, the most famous
inhabiter was Erazem Lueger.
He was a fifteenth century
Robin Hood-like character
who stole from the rich
to give to the needy.
Today, the castle and caves are open
for the public to explore and learn more
about its previous colorful owners.